I have three goals for this video first
I want to show you a way of using gpt4
to get smarter results second I want to
argue that The Benchmark results we have
for GT4 do not reflect its full
abilities and third I want to show you a
system that I am developing somewhat
cheekily called smart GPT that is
already showing significant results on
official benchmarks it remains to be
fully optimized which I think is
exciting in itself I have shown the
system to people at openai who have been
quite impressed and I'm going to end
with some Reflections on where that
might leave us for gpt5 but before I get
into how it works I just want to show
you one example of it in action to wet
your appetite this example comes from a
TED Talk that was released this week so
suppose I left to five close to dry out
in the sun and it took them five hours
to dry completely how long would it take
to dry 30 clothes GPT 4 the newest
greatest AI system says 30 hours not
good on the left you can see gpt4's
original answer and it gives this answer
pretty consistently whenever you prompt
it with the question provided on the
right you can see the final answer from
the smart GPT model which is correct and
it consistently gives that answer I
really like how it gives context as well
and it provides some of the assumptions
that it had in giving this correct
answer now don't you worry there will be
plenty more examples to go through in
this video including another one from
that Ted talk but first I want to give
you an overview of what is this smart
GPT model where did I get my inspiration
for it from and how does it work I'm
going to keep it fairly simple because
it's the beginning of the video and I
know a lot of people won't really care
about the inner details that will come
later in the video but the high level
overview is this there are at least
three things that have been proven to
improve the outputs of gpc4 what's
called Chain of Thought prompting
sometimes called step-by-step prompting
reflection or finding its own errors and
I did an entire video on this called
Gypsy 4 can self-improve and dialoguing
with itself entering into a back and
forth on its own outputs and deciding
which one is best you can see the title
of the papers which contain much more
detailed results of course linked above
now the first paper only came out a few
days ago Midway through my testing so my
results don't even reflect the full
capacity of the model and even if
there's nothing else you take from this
video the results from this paper can
instantly improve the outputs you get
from gpt4 many of you might remember
that prompting GT4 with let's think step
by step improves its results to give you
a very quick reference point just asking
a question to Gypsy 4 gives you 81
accuracy with that prompt let's think
step by step it goes up to 86 but
algorithmically the paper found an
improved prompt that can give you even
better results 89 accuracy all we do and
this is the first part of smart GPT is
we add answer let's work this out in a
step-by-step way to be sure we have the
right answer now I have so much to say
about why I think this works but I know
many of you won't be that interested in
my theories so I'm going to save them to
the end for those who are interested
some of you just want the results so I'm
going to get to those first so far you
might be thinking well thanks Philip
that's a cool prompt I'm going to use
that but what's this whole smart GPT
about is it just a single prompt no I
believe with evidence there are ways of
leveraging even better results than just
using a great Chain of Thought prompt so
let's move on to the next part of the
system these different outputs in the
middle for my tests I typically did
three outputs but of course depending on
the context window it could be far more
than that and I'm going to talk about
ways I could further improve this model
or we could later on in the video just
to restate these outputs are when you
take the user input and add the word
question at the start and then at the
end add answer let's work this out in a
step-by-step way to make sure we have
the right answer at this moment many of
you are thinking what is the point of
multiple outputs it's gpt4 it's just
going to give you the answer it thinks
is best and that's it well actually it
doesn't quite work like that these
models have a temperature between zero
and one I believe the default 4gbt4
might be around 0.5 and simplifying
massively this determines how creative
or conservative the model is in giving
its outputs so given that gpt4 tries to
be fairly creative you don't get the
same output every time the output is
randomly sampled according to an
internal probability distribution so you
can get situations and I face this
hundreds of times where some of the
outputs are correct and others are
incorrect and this is where reflection
comes in sometimes definitely not always
but sometimes quite often gbt4 can
detect the errors in its own output and
many of you will notice at this point
that the prompt that I used to elicit
gpt4 to spot its own errors contains the
same step-by-step prompt I used earlier
that has been shown to produce good
results so to summarize sometimes at
this stage gpt4 detects the errors that
some of its outputs have made definitely
not always there are certain questions
it just simply can't spot the error but
sometimes it can and then I get it to
engage in a dialogue using a format
similar to one in this paper published
last month it's a short dialogue and
this is the step I believe that can be
most optimized in the future I Envision
an entire Council of advisors made up of
gpc4 imitating mathematicians judges Etc
at the moment it's just being a resolver
and printing a final improved output
anyway I'm going to get back to the
theory later in the video because I know
some of you will be getting bored at
this stage and want to see more
practical examples and the results from
my Benchmark tests as I don't have the
gpt4 API key yes I had to manually input
each of these steps hundreds of times
waiting sometimes three hours between
each go because you can only do 25
messages every three hours on the left
you can see the three outputs when you
ask it to think step by step and then
you have the researcher step in the
middle and at the top right and finally
the resolver step notice here I was
using the original let's think step by
step because the paper hadn't yet been
published on improving that prompt but
it's time for the second example from
that Ted Talk and then I definitely will
get onto the benchmarks a different one
I have 12 liter Jog and 60 liter joke
and I want to measure six letters how do
I do it just use the six liter job right
gpt4 spits out some very elaborate
nonsense
foreign
of course I tested smart GPT with that
question and you can see the difference
between the original Gypsy 4 which gives
this incredibly convoluted bad answer
and smart GPT The Final Answer output
now at this point I know many of you
will be impressed but you'll be thinking
I don't have time to input things five
times well I'm developing a model where
it can all be done automatically here is
a preview of how it works but of course
at the moment it has to use GPT 3.5
turbo because I don't have the API key
of gpd4 the epic thing is this you just
ask a single question I've written ask
smartgpt a question and of course it
does take a little bit longer to respond
because it's doing five or six calls via
API but it does output the final answer
from the resolver step I will be honest
and say that GPT 3.5 isn't as good at
reflecting or resolving but this is an
example of a question where the original
chat gbt consistently gets it wrong and
smart GPT 3.5 gets it right using this
program remember all you have to do as a
user is type in a question as normal and
it goes through this entire five or six
step process behind the scenes by the
way this was a question from mmlu which
is a famous Benchmark which I'll get to
in a second here's one last practical
example before I get to that Benchmark I
know many teachers use chat GPT and GT4
to create quizzes for their classes and
here is the same question put through
Gypsy 4 and smart gbt the question is
create a high school algebra quiz with
five questions and answers and
explanations at the end now points for
spotting the difference but if the
teacher had handed out the original quiz
look at the answers for question five it
says the answers are 1 and 1.5 but then
in the explanation it gives the final
answers which are correct by the way of
three and 0.5 so that would really
confuse some students at the reflection
stage smartgbts spotted that error and
resolved it and as you can see the
answer for question five has the correct
answers straight away if at any point
you're wondering if I completed the open
AI chat topt prompt engineering course
the answer is yes but it didn't inform
too much of my thinking it was more for
beginners and I had already factored in
things like giving the model time to
think and writing clear instructions The
Benchmark that I chose to test smartgbt
on was the famous mmlu massive multitask
language understanding Benchmark as you
can see the state-of-the-art is indeed
gpt4 with 86.4 accuracy and you know
open AI think it's a big deal because
it's the Benchmark mentioned on the
front page of their technical report
without boring you too much I extracted
the questions from the test set of the
mmlu data file and I didn't pick the
topics at random I went for those that I
thought gpt4 would find the hardest
delving into the original mmlu paper you
can see that Gypsy 3 found formal Logic
the hardest scoring just over 25 which
is random chance it's a four question
multiple choice test so around 25 or 30
is pretty bad and notice they helped out
Gypsy 3 here they did it few shot
meaning they gave it five successful
examples before asking it a new question
it's the same thing they did with Gypsy
4 they did it five shot but just before
I show you the results there are three
things I want to mention here first I
was curious how smart gbt would do
without any help zero shot second I
wanted to do it zero shot because people
using gpd4 don't typically give five
successful examples before asking Gypsy
for a question they just want code or a
quiz or a poem or an example they don't
often provide five brilliant examples of
code before asking their question and
third if I can prove it works zero shot
then of course future refinements can be
made to push the results even further
and here are the results from the first
25 questions from the formal logic test
set of the mmlu I did many more tests
after this but you can see from this set
if you just to ask the question you get
a lower overall accuracy but of course
68 for GT4 is still a huge improvement
over gpd3s around 25 what happens when
you add let's think step by step which
as we know now isn't the fully optimized
Chain of Thought prompt well on average
you get around 74 75 that was 75
examples inputted manually and I still
have all the tabs open I'm keeping them
open because I'm compiling a spreadsheet
with the actual outputs but what did the
resolver get drawing upon gt4's ability
to reflect and engage in dialogue with
itself it got 84 now notice something
about that number gpc4 zero short got 32
of the questions wrong that was half to
16 after putting it through the smart
GPT system there was one question where
the resolver model gave both a correct
and incorrect answer but I'm counting
that as an incorrect answer for the
purposes of this test anyway from 30 22
to 16 incorrect that is a pattern that
stayed consistent throughout all my
testing that approximately half of the
errors that gpt4 makes can be rectified
if you give it the optimized
step-by-step prompt get it to reflect on
its results and get it to engage in
dialogue and decide on a final answer at
this point for those people losing track
of all the details I want to put into
context what resolving half of the
errors on mmlu might mean in the context
of the big picture here's Leonard Heim
an AI governance researcher suggesting a
score of 95 on the mmlu would be
reflective of agi-like abilities I do
think I have like a 50 chance like
within the next 20 years or so there
might be something will be my call in
AGI or a transformative AI what do I
mean by this well maybe we can measure
it on benchmarks there's like this
famous mmau benchmarks like yeah there's
something which like scores like 95 on
this going back to the results if a
smart gpt-like system can automatically
resolve half of the errors that gpt4
makes on the mmlu that would increase
its score from around 86.4 to around 93
which is not far off 95 remember his
prediction was a 50 chance in 20 years
I'm talking about g54 now for those who
are still skeptical I'm going to show
you plenty more results now and then
walk through the papers that give the
theory as to why this works one thing
that I forgot to mention earlier is that
the human expert level on the mmlu is
89.8 and that's taking the 95th
percentile of human test takers and
remember those are domain experts in
each of these subtopics what we're doing
is testing Gypsy 4 or smart GPT on all
of the topics simultaneously so even if
smart gbt like systems can't quite reach
95 and I think honestly they'll get
pretty close with all the requirements
I'm going to suggest I think they should
almost certainly be 89.8 which is the
human expert test taker level intrigued
by these results I then put it through
the college math test from the mmlu and
remember this was before using the
optimized version of the step-by-step
prompt obviously I'm not going to go
through all the questions here but let's
skip to the final results we have zero
shot accuracy 6 out of 15 which is 40
the average when you add let's think
step by step was 53.5 and then the final
output of the resolver model had a 60
accuracy so it couldn't quite resolve
half of the errors but the overall
pattern held up in case anyone is
wondering about methodology I kept the
formatting identical for every question
I always opened a new tab for each
question it wasn't looking at the
context of what it had already put out
each attempt was fresh aside from the
resolver model which looked at the
context of the researchers output and
again as you can see from example 14 it
wasn't like the researcher could always
spot the errors or that the resolver
could always pick the right option
sometimes the let's think step-by-step
prompt gave the right output but the
resolver couldn't quite distinguish it
the optimized prompt gets a slightly
better output and upon reflection the
researcher can sometimes but not always
spot the errors of those outputs and
sometimes but not always the resolver
can swap based on those flaws which
answer is best these are incremental
improvements sometimes GT4 simply can't
get it right I have noticed a few themes
in those questions anytime it comes to
division multiplication characters or
counting in general deept4 tends to make
mistakes that neither the researcher nor
resolver can spot of course integrating
a few tools via API would likely solve
those issues and I don't want to preempt
the conclusion to too much but I believe
a smart gpt-like system with tools
integrated could probably score around
95 right now on the mmlu especially if
it was helped out with a few shot
prompting to add weight to that
preliminary conclusion I tested it on
certain topics and had to stop because
it simply got the questions right every
single time for example High School
psychology on the mmlu I then tried
pre-history which it also aced before
finding machine learning where I got
more interesting results zooming in this
time the raw score was 65 The Chain of
Thought let's think step-by-step average
was 71.6 and the resolver model got 80
let's now look a little deeper into why
all of these steps might improve the end
result in reply to the original let's
think step-by-step paper which was
published around a year ago Andrei
carpathy said this adding something like
let's think step by step to the prompt
is a way of using the input space for
computation that you'd normally want in
the hidden state of the model instead of
the workings out being done in the
activations of the neural network it's
done in the discrete tokens of that
input space and he adds did not super
see this coming and here is the paper
released three days ago that improves
upon that original prompt they also did
their testing zero shot like me and they
tested many prompts starting like I did
with just direct prompting just asking
the question like 99 of users would do
of gypsy 4. and then they tried like me
the well-established let's think
step-by-step prompt they also
iteratively tested Seven original
prompts as well as the prompt that I've
now integrated into smart GPT the let's
work this out in a step-by-step way Etc
they share my opinion that zero shot
prompting setups have the benefit of not
requiring such task dependent selection
of exemplars you don't have to find
correct examples it just does it all for
you here are the end results for gpd4
that we saw earlier showing the
difference between asking directly your
question and using these refined prompts
notice that this technique is somewhat
model dependent and it doesn't have the
same effect on smaller or weaker models
before we move on to the next paper
there is one somewhat failed prompt that
I want to pick up on it's this
self-critique prompt where they ask
answer the question then critique the
answer based on the critique we consider
the other answer options and give a
single final answer and you might wonder
why didn't that prompt perform best when
we know that reflection and dialogue can
work my theory is because it's trying to
do all of it in one prompt through my
hundreds of experiments I've noticed
that gpt4 can only handle so much in one
go it simply gets overwhelmed or
confused if you ask it to do too much in
one prompt that's why I broke my model
into stages to allow it to show off each
of its abilities one by one and before
we get to the other papers what's my
personal Theory as to why this
eliminates up to half of the errors that
gpt4 makes well my guess is this
remember that gbt4 is drawing on a vast
data set of internet text and let me ask
you what kind of text has things like
question answer let's work this out be
sure we have the right answer the kind
of data that would have that text would
be things like tutorials or expert
breakdowns so I believe you're
triggering more of the weights inside
gpt4 that relate to things like expert
tutorials and so inevitably you're
getting slightly better answers next
I've already explained why you'd get
different outputs when you give the
exact same prompt that's down to
sampling and the temperature of the
model but to simplify massively
sometimes Gypsy 4 will give you an
output that it knows isn't the most
probable it introduces some Randomness
into its sampling by generating multiple
outputs you're getting a larger sample
size reflecting the full range of
probabilities that gpd4 subscribes to
its outputs you're reducing a little bit
some of the randomness that's inherent
in gpd4 outputs next I believe that gpc4
can sometimes spot its own errors
through reflection because prompting
like this triggers a different set of
Weights you could almost think of it as
a different mindset one more focused on
finding errors again if the question is
too hard or involves counting characters
division multiplication as I said
earlier this won't help but a percentage
of the time it can spot its own errors
and point them out notice this is a
separate bit of inference not lumped
into the original prompt and when it
does successfully point out the errors
it can often engage in this dialogue
with itself notice in a meta kind of way
I'm using the step-by-step prompting to
improve the reflection and dialogue so
those are my theories as to why it works
but at the end of the video I'm going to
show you at least five ways I think the
model can be further refined before we
do though I looked up the paper by Zhou
which produced that prompt that did the
best in the previous paper they came to
that special prompt through automatic
prompt engineering but there's something
interesting I want to point out though
on page seven they say we use automatic
prompt engineering to find a prompt
starting with let's that maximizes the
likelihood of correct reasoning steps
then they found the best one that I
integrated into smart GPT let's work
this out in a step-by-step way to be
sure we have the right answer that's the
one I want you to use and they ran their
own benchmarks and of course it did
improve the scores but the interesting
thing to me is they started with let's
each time so even that first stage for
the model might not yet be fully
optimized maybe there's a prompt that
doesn't begin with let's that improves
this initial result still further anyway
back to the papers I know many people
watching this will wonder if I read the
paper boosting theory of Mind
performance in large language models via
prompting and yes I did because they
tested something similar for a theory of
Mind test using similar techniques they
were able to get theory of Mind accuracy
for GPS 4 from 80 to 100 and they
conclude that these results demonstrate
that appropriate prompting enhances
large language model theory of Mind
reasoning and they underscore the
context-dependent nature of these models
cognitive capacities they use that
original prompt let's think step by step
along with some few short examples take
a look at the gpt4 table and you can see
how the let's think step by step
improved the results dramatically and as
I theorized earlier adding few short
examples would push this still further
this is part of why I think that 95
barrier on the mmlu will be broken
probably this year by gpt4 a few other
points from this paper they admit that
there is not currently a theoretical
understanding of why these prompting
techniques are beneficial I've given you
my theory and carpathies but no one
quite knows for sure lastly from this
paper and I found this really
interesting giving it generic few shot
prompts that weren't directly there
theory of Mind actually improve the
outputs slightly more than giving it
direct theory of Mind examples this
opens the door to the first of the five
ways I anticipate smart GPT getting even
smarter it could be possible to come up
with generic few shot prompts that could
be automatically integrated into the
model that don't necessarily relate to
the topic at hand this graph shows the
impact of adding few short examples to
gc3 and if this can be done in a generic
way for gpd4 results could be improved
still further next the boosting theory
of mine paper speculates that
integrating some of these approaches
could boost the performance of weaker
models to beyond their levels of GPT 4's
zero shot accuracy next here is the
original Dira paper that inspired me to
have the researcher and resolver
dialogue at the end of smart GPT as they
say the dearer approach shows
significant improvement over base gpc4
performance and these were open-ended
questions by the way not multiple choice
so this is more generally applicable
than you might think you can see from
this table how results improved after
engaging in this dialogue and that
brings me to the second way I anticipate
smart GPT getting smarter in the future
a longer and more Rich dialogue at the
moment we have this simple research and
resolver two-step dialogue I can imagine
a council of advisors you can imagine a
mathematician chipping in and a
philosopher and a professor each one
tapping into slightly different weights
of gpd4 extracting more hidden expertise
I'm not saying that would transform the
results but it might Edge them another
few percent higher next even with longer
dialogues and different experts we could
find ways of optimizing these prompts
just like we did with the original let's
think step by step that's the Third
Avenue of improvement that I envisage
because I came up with these prompts I'm
sure they could be improved next we
could experiment with different
temperatures remember a lower
temperature makes the model more
conservative relative a Higher One
towards one makes it more creative we
could experiment with a higher
temperature to produce a more diverse
range of outputs at this stage and then
perhaps a more conservative
deterministic temperature for the final
judge or resolver it might not work but
it's worth trying and the fifth
Improvement I know would work
integrating apis for character counting
calculators code interpreters Etc
spending these weeks manually sorting
through the outputs of GT4 on these
benchmarks I can really see where it
goes wrong and it's often by getting
letters in the wrong order or making
mistakes with division it gets the high
level logic right and then makes quite
simple errors basic tool integration
would I am sure push the results still
higher now I know this isn't my usual
video and trust me I have been following
the AI news and we'll get back to that
very soon I'm determined to make those
improvements and push smart gbt even
further but of course that would be
aided massively by getting access to to
the plugins and the gpt4 API key so far
I've had to do all of this manually
which was a lot of work now as you saw
earlier I have drawn on gpt4 to help me
develop a program in replit to automate
this process but at the moment it's GPT
3.5 and honestly the context window
really limits the ability but I do look
forward to the day when I can integrate
gpt4 and put this out as an automatic
model for people to test and play about
with I'm sure that something similar
will ultimately be incorporated by
openai itself maybe as a thoughtful mode
or smart mode a bit like Bing has
creative precise balance Etc each
response does take longer but as you've
seen the outputs are noticeably better
if the results of models like this one
do officially exceed the 86.4 that
openai talked about in the gpt4
technical War I do think that would
reveal quite a few things first the
openai isn't even aware of the full
capabilities of its own model I don't
even know if they anticipated things
like Auto GPT I do think it would reveal
that they need to do far more proper
testing of their models before they
release them they should make
falsifiable predictions about what their
models won't be capable of that way we
would know just how much they know about
their own models what we're trying to
avoid is a situation where open AI say
their model can only achieve X and then
when they release the model in the wild
someone comes along and achieves why
where Y is much more impactful than x so
those were the goals of this video to
show you how to get more out of GT4 to
run you through some of the fascinating
papers that have been released in the
last few days and weeks the third goal
was to show you what this model could do
with some official benchmarks and
suggest ways it might get better in the
near-term future of course if you have a
gc4 API key or are an expert in
benchmarking systems like gpc4 I'd love
to hear from you I guess the final goal
was to perhaps suggest to you that
openai don't know as much about their
own models as they might lead you to
believe thank you so much for watching
to the end and have a wonderful day